hello my avatars name is archivist
Llewellyn and I'm asking a question from
Second Life carbon nanostructures can be
grown in high yield inside the pores of
zeolite crystals which are
aluminosilicate semiconductors my
question is does the quality of the
crystals make a difference if so with
crystals grown in space show to have
higher quality be a viable option thank
you so I can begin by answering what are
these zeolites there are crystals with a
small post nanopores in which you can
put nanoparticles in with some order so
this can be a way to prepare and then no
materials and according to the question
it seems I don't know but he seemed that
the growing zeolite in space without
gravity can lead to better quality of
crystals and so may be better on
nanomaterials I don't know about
actually what I can say is that this
material are in competition with many
other technologies that are now able to
prepare a nanomaterial sir I don't I
cannot answer the question I don't know
if we're going is this case on in space
will be willing to I performance
material not toys